Let's add stack views to Pitch Perfect.
Open the storyboard file and navigate to
our place sound view controller scene.
Let's start by changing the background
of the view back to white.
Select the view in the document outline,
and
then, in the attributes inspector,
select white as the background color.
Okay, now to add the stack views.
In Pitch Perfect, we're going to have
a vertical stack view as the base
with horizontal stack views
embedded inside of it.
Make sure the object library is
open here, on the bottom right, and
put in the word stack
into the search box.
You should see horizontal and
vertical stack views.
Drag a vertical stack
view onto the view.
You should see it underneath
the view in the document outline,
here on the left side.
Drag diagonally from the vertical
stack view back to the view.
With the shift-key held down,
select Leading Space to Container,
Trailing Space to Container,
Vertical Spacing to Top Layout guide,
Vertical Spacing to Bottom Layout
guide and select Add Constraints.
This will add the constraints we need,
but
the stack field is still the wrong size.
The reason is that Xcode has put
in constants in the constraints
to keep the stack view at
the size you see here.
We really should move those and
make it the same size as the view.
To do that,
go into each of the four constraints and
set the constant to zero.
As you do this, you'll notice that the
stack view will start to look correctly.
Once you finish setting all the
constants to zero, the stack view will
be the same size as the view for
our play sounds view controller.
Let's make sure the main vertical
stack view has the correct fill and
distribution properties.
Select a vertical stack view
from the document outline.
In the attributes inspector, choose Fill
for the Alignment, and Fill Equally for
the Distribution.
Make sure spacing is set
to zero as you see here.
For this next step, Xcode is going to
display a few auto layout warnings while
we drag the new stack
view onto our scene.
Don't be alarmed, the warnings will be
there while the stack view's empty.
Once we had buttons to it, the stack
view will know how to size itself and
the outer layout
warnings will disappear.
>From the object library,
search for the word stack,
drag a horizontal stack view
underneath a vertical stack view.
Select the horizontal stack view, and
in the attributes inspector make sure
alignment is set to Fill, and
distribution is set to Fill Equally.
In the next step,
we're going to add the buttons for
slow and fast audio playback.